and that was up by our front door it
survived
marcy barlow lost her father five weeks
ago
she's come back to look for the urn
containing his ashes
where do you start in all of this
that is what's left of the garage door
this is the first time she's seen what
was her home
since the fire swept through hers one of
hundreds
lost in the town of phoenix in oregon
taking so much from so many
heart-wrenching
you know just the boy one minute you're
kind of
keeping it together a little bit and
then next you think of something you
lost and remember and all the pictures
and
your kids baby pictures and your wedding
pictures
and my son's what uh video of his
wedding
you know and it's all gone there's no
getting him back
you know it's uh you look around
and you know you're not alone because
there's thousands of other people going
through the same devastation that you
are
it's you're in shock
you're not functioning
you know and thinking you do for a
little while but then
the grief just kind of overtakes you
marcy's one of the few to make it back
into a town still under evacuation
orders
willow mccloud stayed as the fire
arrived
watching the judo academy burn where her
uncle had taught
his picture one possession she was ready
to flee with
she also saw her neighbor's home burn
can you put into words what it's like
when you see what's happened to
someone's
home and
we had dinner with our neighbor last
night that came in that
she hasn't been there yet she just
watched it from our yard she just looked
she didn't walk up close and
i really can't i'm sorry i think right
now we're
you know that that's just too
overwhelming
it's been a week now that's a long time
to be scared in your house
oh lump in the throat so um
i think people are relieved but they're
it's it's really hard right now because
we're
we're really sad for our friends and our
community
and then the people that still have
house houses standing we feel guilty
the police are patrolling phoenix so
worried are people about looting
there'll be a lot of anxiety a lot of
grief before this town
rises from the ashes greg milam sky news
phoenix
in oregon